yeah just remind me to never complain
about anything ever again you know what
I mean don't don't let me complain about
anything ever again I mean I don't
consider myself a big complainer but
come on this is just we have no reason
to complain about anything yeah yeah man
what's crazy to one of one of the
heavier parts there where I felt it was
when he talked about the claustrophobia
heart yeah I know you have an issue hang
it it's there but it's not it's not I'm
not super sensitive to it but it's
something I know I feel that then that's
like a tough one to get over you know
yeah danken specially going through all
that stuff first and then you got a deal
with the club I don't know man
this might be too heavy for me well it
was too heavy for a lot of people and
yeah I mean it's almost like you you we
almost don't need to have a discussion
about this book you know Mike just just
stop talking about it everyone go read
it I get it you know and just let's move
on you know yeah because you know like
like I said it just makes you realize
just just what kind of suffering there
can be and how good you've got it how
good you've got it I'm gonna go to bed
tonight in my bed and that's gonna feel
good I'm going to appreciate that I'm
appreciated every night you know yeah so
because you think about like some little
things you don't even think about but
they're like a real luxury it's just
things that you really enjoy but you
don't even think about it they're just
they're just like or whatever like for
me I really like a nice cold you know
big bottle of water you know I have a
big just a big bottle of water I
completely take it for granted
yeah when I go to work out the morning I
drop a couple ice cubes in there fill it
up it's all nice filtered and whatnot
yeah oh I don't think anything about
that you know that would be like heaven
heaven and then you get you know you go
to bed at night you
just crawl into the to the the 500
thread so I don't know there's there's
some kind of sheets that is but whatever
they are the kind of cotton sheets that
are all nice yeah you climb into those
you don't think about that you're not
thankful for that every night yeah
but pretty much everything like I said
for everything pretty much everything
even like oh yeah you know how you're
breathing right now yeah look at
consider that compared to that what you
just read there just we'll just
breathing let's just start with that
let's just break it down with air yeah
yeah I look at the beginning I remember
um the Cable Guy was coming mm-hmm which
already sounds silly I know and um and
he was late he's supposed to come as to
was the cutoff right where he was gonna
cut it was like you know before the
struggle is real
where little guy was late yeah so he
can't I don't know to 15 or something
and I had to go I want to see go to work
out or something this is getting worse
and worse I know the C&S cable boy is
gonna be tea yeah for my steam it's like
we're all my movies you know he's fixing
not fixing pronounced like a bracket or
something yeah and yeah and that's one
of the things I thought of primarily
when you said think of all the little
luxuries so not only I'm not only am i
complaining about something I don't need
I'm complaining about something that I'm
getting like a supreme luxury I'm
complaining about that you know because
it didn't come 15 minutes of all things
before the time um that it did yeah I'm
gonna check myself it's a good idea I'm
gonna check myself too